we were knocking him because it was a
horrible speech there is one really
clever thing he did though and it was
right at the top which yeah he he got
those two lines in about Kevin McCarthy
and about Mitch McConnell and there were
lines to say I'm actually looking
forward to working with you Kevin I hope
I don't hurt your career here by saying
that but I think Kevin I Think You're
great and Mitch you know it's going to
be great to work with you too Mitch and
that's obviously a dig at Maga but it's
really a dig at both those guys because
uh he knows he's gonna come in the eyes
of Mega of course yeah and that was
after the most contentious house battle
in what 150 years I think it was